[Music]
hi everyone it's seven o'clock in the uk
welcome wherever you're watching us
around the world this morning when boris
johnson confirmed that the easing of
lockdown measures in
england was being delayed he said it was
to allow for more people to be
vaccinated
now there are plans for jabs to be made
compulsory for all
care home staff looking after elderly
people we'll discuss
that in just a moment with the
international trade secretary liz truss
as well as asking her about that trade
deal she's brokered
with australia and whether farmers need
to be worried
also ahead
it hurts but it works
[Music]
meet the tick tock doctors i'll chat to
the medics taking to social media to
dispel myths
about the covid vaccine and in addition
to that let's do
business the mayor of london sadiq khan
on why he's calling for more financial
support for
firms until all coveted restrictions are
dropped you'll join us
at 9 20. it's wednesday the 16th
of june a jab for a job it's understood
covered vaccinations will be made
compulsory for care home staff
who work with elderly people nhs workers
may also have to fall in line
a failure to weather the storm
scientists say the uk is less prepared
to deal with climate change
than it was five years ago there needs
to be much more action from government
they need they're the ones that need to
put in the money in they're the ones
need to put infrastructure in they're
the ones with the regulations and laws
to force change
israel launches airstrikes in gaza the
military says it's in retaliation
for incendiary balloons fired from the
territory
a presidential summit bart will joe
biden's meeting with vladimir putin
follow convention
in geneva the final countdown
china prepares to launch its first
manned space mission in five years
and some places will be cloudy cool and
murky today with patchy rain but for the
vast majority
sunny and warm again hot and humid in
the south and east and
thunderstorms likely into tonight i'll
have the details for you later
morning everybody if you work in a care
home looking after elderly or vulnerable
people
then you'll have to have a coronavirus
vaccination ministers want to make the
jabs mandatory and has said
to want to extend the move to cover all
nhs
staff let's bring in our political
correspondent tomorrow cohen who is
standing by for us this morning hello to
you um
tomorrow so tell us more about what the
government is hoping to achieve here
morning kay good morning we understand
that later this week they'll announce
that
all staff working in care homes for the
elderly will have to have a coronavirus
vaccine it's going to be within the next
16 weeks or they face
losing their job or being redeployed
away from frontline duties the
government has said
all along that they believe vaccines are
the way out of this
pandemic and we understand that they'll
say that thousands of lives could be
saved with this policy now in terms of
uptake
at the moment the nhs england figures
show that over 80 percent of care home
staff have had their first vaccine
almost 70 have had their second but the
concern
is that this is not uniform in some
local areas the uptake is far
far lower and we know the health
secretary has said earlier this year
that some care home chains
want this to be compulsory the concern
is of course and
why some trade unions representing the
sector
oppose it is because they fear that it
will exacerbate already acute staff
shortages
in the social care sector which are also
a real problem
and as far as this trade deal is
concerned with australia what's it
looking like
well boris johnson was very pleased to
announce it yesterday holding some
vegemite
in the downing street garden with the
australian prime minister
scott morrison and it has to be said
although this is the first post-brexit
trade deal to be negotiated from scratch
and the government will be very pleased
with that there are some concerns about
farming
and whether the farming sector is going
to be
have farmers forced out due to cheaper
imports of meat that
comes to a lower welfare standard and
that's what they've been
saying all along liz trust and the
government say
that they've put protections in that
deal so for the first 10 years there
will be quotas
on how much australian meat can be
imported but the important thing is we
have not seen the text of this deal
we had an agreement and an elbow bump
yesterday
but the fine detail will not come out
until later
this year and there are questions about
whether for the small
amount that it adds to our national
income the government's own projections
suggest
only a fraction of a percent uh it is
worth that hardship
for farmers and as far as farmers are
concerned i mean looking at the figures
um they are not at all happy suggesting
this is um
showcased rather than substance
that's right yes the farmers have
expressed concerns all along that
some of them will be forced to the wall
i mean what michael gove told us
yesterday
is that he didn't expect this to be a
huge the uk to be a huge export market
for australia because of course it is 9
000 miles away
and their biggest export markets for
produce will probably
remain in asia but farmers remain
concerned
about the whole post-brexit landscape
they're going to see their subsidies
phased out over the next few years it's
not clear what support they'll get for
government
there and although government ministers
including liz trust have said well they
can find new opportunities
to export abroad it's still unclear
what the terms of that will be but the
government say that this trade deal is
going to be a win for particular
sectors what they call iconic british
brands whether that's
chocolates or cars or whiskey and they
say
that british consumers will be able to
enjoy um australian products like
australian wines
at a cheaper price than they they do at
the moment because all of those taxes
and tariffs
will be eliminated okay tomorrow for now
thanks very much indeed quick look at
what's happening as far as the
coronavirus figures are concerned
for the uk today the latest data shows
there were 7 673 new coronavirus cases
reported
in the last 24-hour period and 10 death
that means that the
total number of people who've died
within 28 days of a positive test now
stands
at 127 900
another 132 627 people have received
their first vaccinations and 235
928 people have received their second
that now means 30.2 million people have
now received both doses
of a vaccine lots to talk to with the
international trade secretary
liz trustee is with us now hi good
morning good morning thanks for joining
us this morning
um let's start with that trade deal
should we um
those who are being critical say it's
more showcase and substance
well i completely disagree with this
this is the first uk trade deal that
we've struck
from scratch since brexit it's not just
important in itself it's got
huge opportunities with australia
whether it's about the under 35s being
able to go there
for three years without any farm work
requirement whether it's about
tariffs reduced on all british goods
from whiskey to cars but what's more
it's also
about access to the wider pacific market
so we want to sign up to the
trans-pacific partnership
a market of 11 countries 500 million
people
and doing this australia deal is a key
part of that as well and of course
that's where the growing demand is sure
but that's
all the kind of products and services
that we that's why people are saying
that's why it's
a showcase because actually worth 0.1
percent of
increase in gdp about 1.20 per household
per year well that's a static analysis
but what that analysis doesn't take into
account
is that those economies are growing and
they're growing fast
so we're expecting trade with australia
to increase by 30
by 2030 and with a wider trans-pacific
area
we're expecting it to increase by 65 so
what i'm doing
is striking these trade deals that are
going to put the uk in a very strong
position
you know in 2030 and 2040 and 2050
because our businesses whether it's
financial services or technology
or farmers or
whiskey they will have a bigger market
to sell into
and the british will have better access
than other countries so this deal for
example with australia
we have now got more access for brits to
go and live and work
in australia than the americans have all
the japanese have so we've got a real
strategic advantage
okay at the expense of our farmers some
might say um a huge increase in meat
imports into the united kingdom 25 times
what it is at the moment is what the cap
is likely to be
emily thornbury the shadow trade
secretary as you know saying
send our farmers to the wall and the
national farmers union representative
chairman in fact uh minette batters
saying uh we're really gonna have to
look at this very carefully it's just
not good for our farmers
well what we are doing is we're making
sure there's a transition period for
farmers of 15 years
so we're going to give australia the
same access
that the eu have to our market in 15
years time
the eu already has quota free access
to the uk so they already sell us 230
000
tonnes of beef per year what this deal
is talking about is next year
it'll be 35 000 tons so we we
import far more beef from the eu than we
do
from australia and what we're talking
about is rectifying that in 15 years
time
it's on a sliding scale though of course
isn't it it's on its guiding scale but
none of
none of the amounts on that sliding
scale are as big
as the amount we import from the eu okay
and first of all
australia mainly sell into the asia
pacific market
which has much higher prices than here
in the uk and europe
but what the deal will also enable us to
do is get more
opportunities for our farmers in those
markets like
vietnam like those other markets where
there is growing demand
for british beef and lamb so we need to
look outwards
i think we've got to stop being
defensive and look at where the
opportunities are
okay how will this trade deal complicate
matters in northern ireland
given that currently the government
doesn't want to enforce any checks as
far as northern ireland is concerned the
eu
is reducing checks on australia goods
the eu is going to be looking at this
and saying
hang on a minute well this trade deal is
fully compatible with a northern ireland
protocol
but what the issue is in northern
ireland
is we need the eu to be pragmatic
about the checks that are undertaken and
that was always the way the protocol was
drafted
it requires compromise between the
parties
and the eu need to be reasonable and
that's what lord frost is asking for a
deal's a deal though isn't it
well the deal was clear within the terms
of the northern ireland protocol that
there had to be
a pragmatic approach and that's what we
need to see
from the eu so we might go past the 30th
of june with our negotiations in order
to try to get this deal
over the line it's already over the line
but sorted well lord frost continues to
be in discussions with the eu to sort
this situation out but i would urge the
eu
to be responsible and be pragmatic
to sort this issue out let me talk about
vaccines if i may a mandatory
vaccination for care home staff is that
the case
well we are currently consulting on this
issue
what we do know is that it's incredibly
important
that staffing care homes are vaccinated
we've got a hugely vulnerable population
in our care homes and making sure
that staff are vaccinated is a priority
and everybody
who has the opportunity for a vaccine
should take up that opportunity because
it's helping protect all of us
and keep all of us safe okay sacked if
they don't have one
two i i i'm not gonna comment
because we haven't we haven't got the
well we haven't responded to the
consultation it'd be responding wrong of
me
to prejudge that consultation but it's
clearly if you had a parent who was in a
care home
i would want to make sure i would want
the staff to be vaccinated
of course i would because i would want
my parents to be protected
what about nhs staff well i think that
everybody who has the opportunity to
have a vaccine
should have that vaccine and that's what
we want to make sure is that all adults
are vaccinated and what jeopardy should
there be if you don't have that
vaccination
well these are all issues that we're
looking at as part of the consultation
we will
respond to that consultation i can't
prejudge that but you do think but i'm
very much of the view
that we need to protect everybody in
society and the vaccine is a way to do
that and we've seen the huge progress
we've been able to make
as a result of our very strong record in
vaccination
just reading um jacob reese mogg this
morning i'm sure you've been reading
what he's had to say as well it was
actually on his podcast or more cast i
think he calls it very clever
um and it's been picked up by a lot of
the newspapers this morning
saying that we can't run a society to
stop hospitals uh
becoming full isn't that exactly what we
are doing at the moment
what we're doing is we are taking a
pragmatic approach
the key is making sure that everybody
gets vaccinated
by the 19th of july we'll have all
over 40s vaccinated so that we are
protected
as a society that's what we need to do
in order to be able to
fully open up the economy but what do we
think about what jacob reese mulcah said
i mean he's completely gone off the
reservation
well i haven't actually read his uh read
his blog
read his blog this morning uh but i let
me tell you he says
um lockdown cannot drag on just to
prevent people seeing a doctor
and that we can't run a society to stop
hospitals being
uh being full well i agree with him that
lockdown
shouldn't drag on we want to bring an
end to it we've already
taken a number of steps to open up parts
of the economy
things are freer than they were a few
months ago
but i think we need to hold our nerve to
make sure
that we keep levels of the virus down
and the way to do that is through
vaccination
yeah but does he not understand that
he's literally the government's policy
is uh to have lockdown or easing of
lockdown but still
restrictions in place at the moment in
order to stop our hospitals being full
i mean it's fundamentally the point
isn't it the well the whole point
is fundamentally to protect people and
to stop
people uh suffering severe coverage and
dying and that is why we're doing this
we're protecting lives
that is the ultimate aim do you accept
that he's misspoken then
well i i don't know i come you just you
just read it out to me and
uh papers no i mean it's no secret well
jacob
jacob jacob has his you know his views
and that's
those are his views but what i'm telling
you is the what
the reason we are doing this the reason
we are taking these measures
is to protect lives and that's what's
important but the more serious point is
that it's
the discontent with with an extension to
lockdown
um is now reaching the front bench he's
the leader of the house
when you go out and about in the uk
and talk to people about their
experiences on lockdown what they want
to see
there is huge support for the prime
minister's approach
of being cautious and making sure
that we do have people vaccinated before
we fully open up the economy we don't
want to be in a position
where we have to go backwards because
we've seen a spike
and that is why the vaccination program
is so vitally important and
there's huge public support for that
have you had both your jobs
i haven't i've got i've got one due on
saturday okay so i will be
i will be double backs then did you have
oxford i did
yeah poorly no actually not at all i had
to do it i had to do a media around the
next morning so i couldn't
i couldn't be poorly two days i was so
poorly but having said that
i'm 100 invincible now i've had both
jobs and yours is this weekend
it is good thank you very much thank you
yes thanks a lot coming up on the
program
for you this morning at a quarter to
eight we'll talk to campaigners and
those with relatives and care homes
as mps call for urgent action to reform
the care system
how old should we be to get married if
you're a teenager
in love the former home secretary
studied javid wants the minimum legal
age to be raised to 18.
we'll ask him at five past eight
[Music]
then at uh 20 pass we'll speak to the
former formula one world champion nico
rosberg
about why he's pumped up about dumping
petrol
and now leading a global environmental
festival
but first the latest inflation figures
from the office for national statistics
have just been released they show the
rate of inflation rose to 2.1 percent in
may up from
1.5 in april our business correspondent
paul kelso standing by for us hi
paul um analyze this for us if you would
please good morning
yeah good morning kay yes uh as you say
the
uh inflation rate has increased to 2.1
percent
up from one and a half percent in april
which in itself
was up uh more than 100 on the previous
month this is all year on year figures
so we should be comparing them in our
minds
to where prices were a year ago when we
of course we were
emerging from the first lockdown and
what they tell us
is that the recovery in the economy is
well underway in fact the economy is in
some sense is roaring back
perhaps a little too fast for some
tastes
which is why prices are rising the main
drivers of these price increases
uh cake clothing and shoes carp motor
fuel
cost of petrol and diesel at the pump a
great deal more than a year ago because
the oil price has risen substantially
and recreational goods so we're going
out and spending money
both outside the home and inside food
and drink
has driven a lot of this uh for that
purchased outside the home of course
remember a year ago that was a very
limited choice these figures for may so
we were still locked down a year ago
now of course people are out and about
one significance perhaps of this number
today 2.1 percent it's above
the bank of england's target rate for
inflation of two percent
and we've seen concern not just in the
uk but around
the world in global economies about uh
increasing
inflation in the u.s it's been they've
been spooked a little we know that
there's supply problems so while there's
great demand from consumers like us
uh manufacturers are struggling to get
goods to us will the bank of england act
and
address the interest rate the wide
expectation is not
now but perhaps sooner than expected
okay paul thank you also making the news
for you this morning
israel says it's launched airstrikes in
the gaza strip in retaliation for
incendiary balloons
fired from the territory it's the first
major clash since 11 days of fighting
between the two sides ended late last
month 21 and 22 year olds are being
asked to book their coronavirus
vaccinations
the nhs says it will send out nearly a
million texts today asking them to come
forward
18 to 20 year olds are expected to be
invited before the end of the week
new research suggests the number of
people taking a coronavirus vaccine
could increase if more treatment for
fear of needles was available
a study by the university of oxford
claims around a quarter of adults in the
uk
are scared of injections me included
scotland yard has promised to review
allegations that galen maxwell
was involved in trafficking grooming and
abusing women and girls
in the uk the former girlfriend of
convicted sex offender jeffrey epstein
is in custody in the united states
accused of recruiting teenage girls for
him to sexually abuse
the uk is even less prepared to deal
with climate change conditions hitting
the country now than it was
five years ago that's according to the
government's own climate change experts
they say new build homes are poorly
designed and can't cope
with the impact of rising temperatures
here's our climate change correspondent
lisa holland
with rock from local quarries aberdeen
is known as the granite city
distinctive architecture but old granite
buildings are notoriously difficult to
keep warm
this is the cavity and this cavity is
ventilated to under the floor and this
is vital in order to keep the inner wall
here dry engineer david mcgrath is
developing ways to make homes more
energy efficient
and is insulating his son's granite
house in aberdeen
he believes not enough is being done to
help people retrofit their homes
for all properties like this is vitally
important
in on two fronts one we have to
do some mitigation for climate change
but actually a lot of the
illnesses that are formed are because of
the very construction of these
properties
it's not just buildings that are poorly
insulated or overheat
which pose a risk to our health and
welfare
people nature and infrastructure are all
threatened by climate change
there needs to be much more action from
government they need they're the ones
that need to put the money in they're
the ones need to put infrastructure in
they're the ones in the regulations and
laws to force change
i mean people will will change when they
when they're told to do so and we will
take individual action but we need
support in that
buffeted by extreme weather aberdeen is
a city which sees itself as on the front
line of climate change
in a stark warning the climate change
committee which advises the uk
government how to get to net zero
says the country is unprepared for what
lies ahead
i think the government's response has
been inadequate we've seen the the
the science of climate change has
improved progressively over time we've
become more and more aware of the risks
that we face and yet we haven't seen
a commensurate response from the
government to those risks and it's time
for the government to now act on that
the climate change committee says
ambition needs to be matched with
adaptation
and insists we're now in a critical
period
for dealing with the impact of climate
change in the uk
lisa holland sky news aberdeen
and for similar news and stories from
the people trying to stop
climate change you can watch the daily
climate show on sky news
you can join sam washington 6 30
and 9 30 this evening usually anna jones
of course
on holiday at the moment or if you're on
the go you can download and listen to
the latest edition
of our weekly climate cast podcast
available now wherever you get your
podcast from
more headlines for you this morning now
elderly campaign groups say the number
of pensioners in
poverty has exceeded 2 million with
black and asian
older people more at risk of struggling
financially
age uk is calling on all older people to
check their eligibility for pensioner
credit
over fears they'll miss out
we're looking at how people compare with
the rest of the population
and sometimes some groups get left
behind a bit
but we do know that one of the reasons
why people are living
in poverty unnecessarily is because they
aren't claiming any benefit entitlements
that they should be
so people are missing out and
particularly on pension credit there's
nearly a million
pensioner households who should be
receiving the benefit pension credit
it's claimed more than half of firms
outside the biggest 350 companies still
have no female bosses
the group women on boards uk says less
than half of these firms meet the uk's
goal of women occupying a third
of executive roles today marks the fifth
anniversary of the death of the labour
mp joe cox
in a statement her family said they were
optimistic about a future where people
recognize
we have things in common
china's confirmed it will launch its
first manned space mission in five years
tomorrow morning
three astronauts are due to spend
several months on border space station
and will also carry out
a space walk
more than four billion dollars has been
wiped off the coca-cola share price
after this gesture by cristiano
ronaldo the footballer removed two coke
bottles from the desk during his euro
2020 news conference
he then toasted with a bottle of water
goodness me need to fix that don't they
quit look at the weather for you here's
nas
good morning it's all going on today
we've got hot and humid conditions
for some we could see the highest
temperature of the year so far others
seeing cloudy skies patchy light rain
and drizzle
and then tonight thunderstorms
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning on the face of it for most
places today it's looking fine and dry
with some good spells of sunshine a warm
day
but rather hot and humid around central
southern and eastern areas
where around the south and east we're
likely to see the highest temperature of
the year so far and for some it's
looking cloudy
mainly this afternoon across southern
parts of scotland northwest england the
west of wales and down towards parts of
devon and cornwall
becoming brighter after a cloudy and
damp murky start around eastern parts of
ireland
north and northern ireland too and for
the rest of violent northern ireland
scotland
there will be brighter sunny spells that
will feel warm but as i said hot and
humid down towards
central southern and eastern areas the
highest temperature of the year so far
likely down towards the southeast 30 to
31 degrees celsius than tonight
torrential downpours with thunderstorms
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
i was trying to remember the name for
chinese astronauts and it wouldn't come
to me i've googled it
do you know what they're called yeah
technonauts technauts is what they're
called if they're chinese astronauts
stuart my uh director is very impressed
with that uh also coming up for you a
chance for me to bring you a story with
a very happy ending
this morning i know
a magical stormzy has been released back
into the wild after he was rescued in
suffolk he was found last month
having collapsed in the cold wet weather
the rspca says they have been
able to return him after identifying the
set that he came from
how did they know that don't they all
look the same i don't know
still to come on on the breakfast show
for you this morning joined by a former
senior us diplomat ahead of today's
face-to-face meeting
between joe biden and vladimir putin in
switzerland
how lovely that's next
hi again everybody uh sky news
understands the government wants to make
it mandatory for care home staff in
england to have a coronavirus vaccine
a consultation is also underway on
whether all nhs staff should be forced
to have the jab
short time ago the international trade
secretary liz trust told me
vaccinating care home staff is a
government priority
it's incredibly important that staffing
care homes
are vaccinated we've got a hugely
vulnerable
population in our care homes
and making sure that staff are
vaccinated
is a priority and everybody who has the
opportunity
for a vaccine should take up that
opportunity because it's helped
protect all of us ms trusts has also
said that the government's new agreement
with australia comes at a time
when trade is already growing between
the two countries she assured me the
post-brexit deal
would provide a major economic boost to
the uk
we're expecting trade with australia to
increase by 30
by 2030 and with a wider trans-pacific
area we're expecting it to increase by
65
so what i'm doing is striking these
trade deals
that are going to put the uk in a very
strong position
you know in 2030 and 2040 and 2050
because our businesses whether it's
financial services or technology
or farmers or
whiskey they will have a bigger market
to sell into
and the british will have better access
than other countries so this deal for
example with australia
we have now got more access for brits to
go and live and work
in australia than the americans have all
the japanese have so we've got a real
strategic advantage
let's bring in our political
correspondent tomorrow cohen that may
well be the case
but uh our farmer's not at all happy in
the nfu chairperson saying we need to
look at this
yes although there are protections built
into this trade deal to account for the
concerns
of farmers that they will be flooded
with cheaper
imports of meat which are produced to a
less high welfare standard because the
farms in australia have different
standards
and are far bigger the governments say
that over
10 years there will be quotas which will
be phased out
but the farming community say this may
not stop hundreds if not more
farms going to the wall because of all
the
changes to the subsidies that come with
leaving the european union
and the fact that they might now be
maybe undercut by the trade deals that
the government
is now doing now liz trust rejected that
saying that farmers will be able to have
more opportunities to sell their produce
further afield
in australia and the pacific region she
also
dismissed the idea that according to the
government's own
figures which said that consumers would
benefit from this trade deal
to the tune of 34 million pounds which
sounds like rather a lot except it's
only just over one pound per household
she said that's the figure now all the
growth in trade over the next 10 years
or so
is going to come from australia and the
pacific and the government very much
hopes that this trade deal
that boris johnson sealed yesterday with
the australian prime minister
will pave the way for a much bigger one
with seven countries in the pacific
region
okay finale thank you thanks tomorrow uh
two of the most powerful world leaders
come face to face later on today when
joe biden and vladimir putin meet in
switzerland it takes place just days
after president putin said relations
between russia and the united states
were at their lowest
point where do they go from here let's
find out with the former u.s ambassador
to
ukraine and director of the eurasia
center
atlantic council and that's john herbst
hello to you
thank you for joining us mr ambassador
on the programme this morning
where do you see the relationship
between the us and russia at the
um the moment is exactly unfortunately
where it should be
which is a point and it's at a low point
because mr putin has been running
wild on globally for the past seven or
eight years
um his war on ukraine his intervention
in syria
his intervention in elections in the
united states and across europe
including in your brexit election
he's been behaving like a rogue actor
and it's taken the united states couple
of years but over the past five or six
it has begun to push back hard against
moscow's provocative behavior
and the kremlin doesn't like it hence
the relationship is not in a good spot
how does president biden's approach to
president putin
differ to that of president trump
president trump had an odd and
unexplained affection
for mr putin and for russia and he he
expressed that
from time to time including during his
infamous press conference with putin in
helsinki
in 2018 but his administration despite
that pushed back
pretty strongly against the aggressive
policies of the kremlin
biden has a clear understanding of those
aggressive policies
and he and his administration also push
back
the important difference is that biden
again clearly understands the problem
and expresses that publicly as he did
during his op-ed
the op-ed he wrote for the washington
post a few days ago
so he has been tr as we know he's been
to the g7 in cornwall he's been to nato
and now he's going to be uh
meeting uh president putin very
different situation to what he's had to
do
over the last few days in that the
leaders that he's been meeting he's had
to try and mend
fences between the united states uh and
whichever country's leader he's talking
to
a very different situation from what
you're saying with president putin where
he
uh president trump had a very good
relationship with him or a good
relationship certainly
um you're right that the meetings with
nato the meetings of the g7
and also with european union leaders
were all designed to
re-establish reassure our partners that
we are good allies
and that was a smart play to do for
going to see mr putin
because this underscores the american
strength
um globally and it makes putin's job a
little bit harder
and that's a good thing how significant
then is the meeting in geneva what do
you expect to come out of it
um if biden pursues the right um
positions which i think he will
no very little will come out of it the
most important thing is that biden has
to tell putin
stop your war in done boss in ukraine
stop into fury in american elections
stop interfering in elections across the
globe stop these ransomware attacks on
the united states
um and also do not do not um kill mr
navalny
those are all difficult messages for
putin to hear
uh but biden will also say that while
we will push back hard against all these
aggressive policies of yours
we have some things we can discuss where
you may want to work with us for example
on strategic arms strategic nuclear arms
that's what i hope and expect mr biden
will say if he does
um putin will obviously not be happy
about those first messages i've just
described
but he may decide that yes it makes
sense to sit down with the united states
and deal
with the nuclear arms issues yeah don't
do any
yeah sorry mr ambassador don't do any of
those things
um uh president biden will say to
president putin or else what
well you've already seen um an american
response in the past to such
behavior um principally we've levied
sanctions on the kremlin
for such behavior including as recently
as two months ago
um in connection with the war in ukraine
the united states has provided
significant military support to ukraine
as well as sanctioned the kremlin
uh but i think the other things that
biden should do
this is actually very important there
needs to be some american
cyber attacks on russia they don't need
not need to be spoken of publicly
but we need to demonstrate to mr putin
that we have a stronger cyber capability
than russia
and that they will pay dearly if they
continue such attacks on the united
states
um one assumes that potentially that
might be happening already if they're
not
uh spoken about publicly mr ambassador
but nevertheless let me ask you very
briefly before
i let you go the chair of the uk defense
select committee told me last week that
the west is facing a new cold war
with russia would you agree with that
assessment
well um i would say we've been in a cold
war for many years
it took the west and the united states
too um some time to understand that but
putin has been pursuing a policy
directly contrary to american
and nato interests including britain and
britain's interests
since at least 2007 when it launched a
cyberware
attack on estonia and then 2008 when it
invaded georgia
and then 2014 when it seized crimea
and began its war in dunbas in ukraine
not to mention all the electoral
interference we've talked about
going back the last seven or eight years
so the united states and the west again
took them a little bit of time to
realize this
but once they did they began to push
back and that's when moscow began to
talk about a cold war
but it's a cold war that the kremlin
launched let's understand that
and we're merely protecting ourselves mr
ambassador
thank you so much for staying up into
the early hours in washington to speak
to us we do appreciate it thanks a lot
my pleasure thank you thank you
uh coming up why there are calls for the
adult care system to be overhauled we'll
be talking about that
in just a moment
[Music]
calls this morning for urgent reform of
the care system in
england the house of commons public
accounts committee says there needs to
be
proper funding and warns the pandemic
has had what it calls a devastating
impact on
on the service uh fraser mortar reports
enjoying the sunshine and some
traditional seaside fun
the residents have sent cecilia's in
scarborough
here as in hundreds of other care homes
lives have been lost
during the pandemic taking a toll on the
residents their families
and the staff those who work in the care
sector
say today's report by the public
accounts committee doesn't tell them
anything new
they know action is needed and with many
homes now operating at only 80
capacity they need it to happen soon i'd
like the government to be bold and
committed and to actually give us a date
when it's
going to start and finish the reforms
really if they can't do that then i
suggest someone else comes in
and actually does it because we've heard
promises broken promises
over more than two decades and enough is
enough it's about time someone stood up
and said
this is when it's happening the report
concludes that care is not properly
funded
lacks transparency and urgently needs
reform
we've said really that the government
has failed on social care and not just
the devastation that it faced during
covid but it has a track record that we
have highlighted a number of times
not delivering on many aspects of
supporting people in care homes and
getting care at home
residents like david who's been at
census elias for seven years greatly
appreciate the work of their carers
they're worth the white teen gold they
come here at seven o'clock in the
morning ready for work
and we don't get um tonight at night and
leave it out that's a long shift you
know
and they're on the face imagine the
mortgages they're walking around all the
time
you know just phenomenal the staff
themselves
love their jobs but often feel
undervalued
you can't teach someone to care they
either have care or they don't have care
and to be able to look after people
especially with the needs that our our
residents have
that it takes some doing today's report
calls for this government to finally
deliver the reforms that have long been
promised
starting with an outline by next month
on how much support is needed
to cope with the immediate crisis caused
by kovid 19.
fraser moored sky news scarborough
[Music]
let's talk about this in more detail
gene adamson um
is a bereaved family member
last year sadly lost her father to
covert 19 whilst in
a care home um hi gene it's lovely to
see you this morning thanks for joining
us
um tell us what happened to your dad
cleo i think his name was wasn't it
yes my father was was in a care home
um he was admitted there after having
had a
stroke um and was left quite debilitated
and um he spent uh 18 months in the care
home
altogether before he contracted covid
um and unfortunately passed away um
during the the first wave of um the
pandemic
um april last year what were your
favorite memories of him do you have
some when you think about him that bring
a smile to your face
yes i do um my dad was a trooper
and and he was a family man as well when
he went into the care home um
they had the doctors had given him three
to six months
to live um because he also had a brain
tumor
and and they'd given him that time to
live um
and the doctor used to go in each week
because he was on end of life care and
say
um okay you know do we need to review
anything here and
and in the end the doctor said well why
is this man on end of life care you know
he's
uh he's hearty and strong and you know
he
he loved to sing he would sit up and
sing in bed every day
um you know he was such a peaceful and
contented soul
um anyway in the end they took him off
the end of life care and and
and he then went on to live another year
before he contracted covet in the home
um and died
um but um my dad i fondly remember my
dad as a
uh he's a he was a windrush pioneer
and uh you know he he loved to wear his
trilby hats
and he would serenade his grandchildren
with
you know old-time west indian uh songs
and um yes he was a a a very
a very strong and uh robust man
robust character yeah but sadly
um he did succumb to kovid and you
weren't
able to visit him were you um towards
the end of his life
in in the care home what impact did that
have on you and the family
that was very very hard on us you know
because we
we we were you know we we couldn't
see him um and unfortunately
because of the effects of stroke he was
unable to communicate with us so we
weren't even able to
you know just speak to him um
you know on the phone or or using an
ipad
so it was very hard um
you know being able to communicate with
him
at any level um but i was i suppose we
we were fortunate in one sense because
he was on the ground floor
of the care home uh we were able to go
and uh
stand by outside his window and at least
we could talk to him
through the window and he could hear our
voice you know
um and he would sometimes respond to
that
um but it wasn't a very difficult time
and wasn't able to
say goodbye to him uh before he died
that was particularly sad i'm sure gene
i'm sure what more do you think
politicians in westminster i mean this
report is coming out soon what more do
you think politicians in westminster
should be doing to help
people like your family
the politicians
need to stop the infighting
and the uh the bickering and the
um self-serving
tactics that they use uh politicians
need to
to realize that
is a tragedy a national tragedy
on a massive scale unprecedented
in our times and it needs to be treated
with the
relevant the appropriate um
degree of urgency and we
need to have a public inquiry
as soon as possible so that we can
understand what happened what went wrong
um why why why things went wrong
and make recommendations and learn
lessons going forward so that we don't
have a repeat of of this
uh the the the massive scale of of
of um uh um tragedy
um again you know the massive
loss of life again i mean we've had
already
you know we've lost over what's 127
000 uh people have lost their lives
covered um we're now possibly
going onto a third wave you know we have
the delta variants now which is um
uh you know rising exponentially
um how many more people need to die
before the government will actually
to take affirmative action get the
inquiry going
and so that we can learn lessons and
avoid further loss of life okay
what needs to happen ended gene i'm sure
your dad cleo would have been very very
proud of you thank you so much for
taking the time to join us this morning
thank you
thank you thanks thank you we're
chatting
um to the government minister this
morning uh about
care homes and the fact that staff do
they need to have compulsory two jobs in
order
to work in care homes in future and also
uh do we think that nhs workers should
compulsory
have two jobs are we talking about that
see what she had to say at the top of
the next hour
but before that something completely
different before the weather
the name might suggest different but
scientists say like us
killer whales make friends
there they are this is the footage from
a team at the university of
exeter and the center for whale research
which they say
proves their theory they believe the
whales spend more time interacting with
specific
other individuals within their pod and
it appears they are picky creatures they
apparently like spending time with wales
of a similar sex and age to themselves
what happens what happens when you fall
out with a killer whale though
i don't know let's find out what's
happening in
wales now here's nas
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning all going on today we've
got fine conditions for
most places but not everywhere there's
cloudy skies likely for this afternoon
across southern scotland
northwest england the western wales down
towards the southwest later
as that band of cloud patchy light rain
also
drizzle also clears from eastern parts
of ireland and northern ireland the rest
of ireland northern ireland scotland
fine and warm but scattered showers
around
the windy north and west hot and humid
for many southern and eastern areas
where we're likely to see the highest
temperature of the year so far
the weather sponsored by qatar airways